robert muller finally comes forward and
makes an enormous statement and the
supreme court speaks out about abortion
we'll explain i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show well you know that
feeling when you've planned out an
entire show and then five minutes before
the show the entire show gets blown up
because robert muller decides that he
finally will speak it's like greta garbo
finally finally muller speaks will get
to all of that and Slyke we will break
in every word he said what it means
it's cryptic it's fascinating we'll get
to all of it first
in 1966 alan greenspan famously said
deficit spending is simply a scheme for
the confiscation of wealth this is
obviously true but the federal deficit
currently touching 1 trillion dollars
per year what are you doing to protect
your savings from this confiscation
scheme alan greenspan offered one
solution saying gold stands in the way
of this insidious process can you afford
another hit to your retirement like the
last downturn when the S&P dropped 50%
hedge against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals the company i trust with
precious metal purchases is Birch gold
group right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver which is
perfect for those who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings for
any future geopolitical uncertainty
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you this
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of risky stocks and bonds into
a precious metals IRA if that's
something you're into to get that
no-cost no-obligation kit text Ben to 47
47 47 again
text the word Ben my name - 47 47 47 ok
so this morning was a very big morning
greta garbo speaks robert muller who's
been absolutely silent for nigh on two
years at this point came to the podium
to announce that he was done mic drop
he's out now we sort of have to back up
for a second and explain what Robert
Muller's role was supposed to be here
who is the special prosecutor in what
was a counterintelligence investigation
originally the counterintelligence
investigation was about Russian
collusion Russian participation in the
2016 election on the basis of that
brought a bevy of prosecutions against
people who are part of the Trump
campaign and not part of the Trump
campaign against people like Paul
Manafort people like George papadopolis
and also against a bunch of Russians who
are actually involved in election in
election interference and so that was
Bob Miller's mandate and then that
mandate expanded to include
investigation of obstruction of justice
now Bob Muller sort of claimed in the
Muller report that he didn't actually
have the authority to recommend a
prosecution of the President of the
United States because of a 1973 office
of legal counsel Department of Justice
memo that said a sitting president
cannot be indicted that memo is somewhat
controversial there are some people who
think the president should be able to be
indicted some people think he shouldn't
but Muller made clear in his report that
the OLC ruling he was going to abide by
now just because he was abiding by the
OLC ruling does not mean that he would
have prosecuted Trump if he had the
opportunity to do so in other words the
OLC the Department of Justice lete
Office of Legal Counsel memo was a
threshold issue so we called a threshold
issue in law the threshold issue is if
that applies can you prosecute the
president that does not answer the
question of if it did not apply would
you prosecute the president
so what Muller's report basically said
is we can't prosecute the president and
we're not even going to reach the other
issue which is should the president be
prosecuted if there were no office of
legal counsel memo
now William bar the Attorney General of
the United States had suggested that
Muller said that he did not see
sufficient evidence in the absence of
the OLC memo to recommend prosecution
right that was what Barr actually
testified before Congress now unless
Barr perjured himself both of those
things can be true that Muller saw the
OLC memo as prohibiting him from
prosecuting and also even without the
oil C memo he wouldn't necessarily have
the evidence to prosecute Trump under
obstruction of justice statutes the
Muller report itself is very damning of
Trump's behavior and so basically what
Muller did and I said this at the time
when Muller did is he basically set out
the pathway to impeachment if Democrats
chose to take it it was obvious that
prosecutors in Miller's office saw the
president as politically impeachable if
not criminally prosecuted and those are
two different standards criminally
prosecuted is guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt now you have to go to prison you
have to pay the legal penalty
impeachment is a
litical standard that does not require a
criminal trial in the same way that you
normally would reasonable doubt doesn't
come into it
so there is an impeachment trial in the
Senate but that does not require a
standard of evidence adduced beyond a
reasonable doubt so all of that is
predicate to what Muller had to say
today so more comes to the podium and
everybody is sort of reading this Muller
statement is a Rorschach test so people
who want to see Trump impeached are
saying here's Muller providing evidence
for impeachment and here is Muller going
after William Bar people who are
defenders of the presidents are saying
Muller is telling us what we already
knew basically Muller isn't adding
anything I think the truth is sort of
somewhere in between as as always
so Robert Muller finally comes to the
podium and his basic statement is I'm
not solving a problems for you I put out
a 448 page report if you want to read it
it's right there in the public view you
can see it we're gonna go through
Muller's actual statement here in great
detail so you're gonna get the whole
thing plus analysis so here's Robert
Muller he gets up in front of that
podium and finally Greta Garbo speaks
good morning everyone and thank you for
being here two years ago the acting
Attorney General asked me to serve as
special counsel and he created two
special counsels office the appointment
order directed the office to investigate
Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election
this included investigating any links or
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign now I have not
spoken publicly during our investigation
I'm speaking out today because our
investigation is complete
the Attorney General has made the report
on our investigation largely public we
are formally closing the special
counsel's office and as well I'm
resigning from the Department of Justice
to return to private life isn't there
for one second so the fact is that a
thousand Democrat screams can be heard
right now Muller is not going to do
their work for them in other words if
Democrats wish to impeach it is now on
them yeah there was this weird hope that
was still out there from the crash and
steen brothers wing of the Democratic
Party that Muller had not closed the
Office of Special Counsel because he was
secretly working
stuff that we didn't know about yet
obviously that is untrue Muller is
saying I am out my report is done we are
done here everything is done if Congress
wants to pick up the ball that would be
on Congress and that's where he goes
next I'll make a few remarks about the
results of our work but beyond these few
remarks it is important that the offices
written work speak for itself let me
begin where the appointment order begins
and that is interference in the 2016
presidential election as alleged by the
grand jury in an indictment Russian
intelligence officers who were part of
the Russian military launched a
concerted attack on our political system
the indictment alleges that they used
sophisticated cyber techniques to hack
into computers and networks used by the
Clinton campaign they stole private
information and then release that
information through fake online and
identities and through the organization
WikiLeaks the releases were designed and
timed to interfere with our election and
to damage a presidential candidate and
at the same time as the grand jury
alleged in a separate indictment a
private Russian entity engaged in a
social media operation where Russian
citizens posed as Americans in order to
influence an election was it there for a
second so first let us point out this
entire thing began as an investigation
not really a criminal investigation a
counterintelligence investigation into
Russian interference in the 2016
election the fact that then morphed into
a quote-unquote criminal investigation
was kind of weird because the fact is
that the counterintelligence
investigation allows all sorts of
resources to the resources to be brought
to bear that wouldn't necessarily be
available in a criminal investigation
without proper proof so this is one of
the complaints of Team Trump the Trump
campaign what they say is why we're
counterintelligence measures being used
that caught us up in them without any
sort of criminal standard being applied
were domestic American citizens the use
of FISA warrants against Carter page for
example without proper evidence that
seems more like a counterintelligence
investigation
than a criminal investigation McCarter
page is an American citizen and the
standard ought to be higher so when we
talk about the difference between a
counterintelligence investigation and a
criminal investigation this becomes very
important the Mullard team and the
investigation generally has straddled
that line and it's made for some real
awkwardness because people don't know
which resources are being brought to
bear and who the target is is the target
Russian actors and then trumping ants in
ancillary fashion swept up into the
investigation or was the target team
Trump and that confusion has led to all
sorts of animus on the part of team
Trump I think not entirely unjustifiably
and a lot of animus on the other side
from people saying listen we're not
targeting team Trump we're trying to
stop Russian election interference that
was our job so what are you ripping on
us for Moeller continues these
indictments contain a legate allegations
and we are not how many on the guilt or
the innocence of any specific defendant
every defendant is presumed innocent
unless and until proven guilty the
indictments allege and the other
activities in our report to describe
efforts to interfere in our political
system they needed to be investigated
and understood and that is among the
reasons why the Department of Justice
established our office that is also a
reason we investigated efforts to
obstruct the investigation the matters
we investigated were of paramount
importance it was critical for us to
obtain full and accurate information
from every person we questioned when a
subject of an investigation obstructs
that investigation or lies to
investigators it strikes at the core of
their government's effort to find the
truth and hold wrongdoers accountable
let me say a word about the report the
report has two parts addressing the two
main issues we were asked to investigate
the first volume of the report details
numerous efforts emanating from Russia
to influence the election this volume
includes a discussion of the Trump
campaigns response to this activity as
well as our conclusion that there was
insufficient evidence
to charge a broader conspiracy oh we're
gonna get two more what Robert Miller
says here in a second first it is
worthwhile noting than when he talks
about obstruction and you'll see later
he talks at length about obstruction of
justice and president Trump and all the
rest he did not bring obstruction of
justice charges against anyone
obstruction of justice charges were not
brought against for example Donald Trump
jr. for theoretically lying to him in
some way obstruction just obstruction of
justice charges will not brought against
Donald McGann those people are not
barred from prosecution so for all the
talk about how Muller is going to say
and you'll hear him say it later that
the president was not cleared of
obstruction of justice under this
investigative standard the fact is he
could have prosecuted a bunch of people
in the Trump administration without
having to worry about the OLC ruling
Muller did not decide to recommend that
so that is worth noting here too because
Trump isn't the only member of Team
Trump now we're gonna get to more of
Robert Muller's very important statement
in just one second first you shouldn't
have to choose between overpriced
designer sunglasses and cheap shades
they're not gonna last you this summer
that is why I'll never wear anything
other than movement sunglasses they
really are fantastic you've heard us
talk about movement disrupting the watch
industry now they're doing it with
sunglasses the LOS angeles-based
accessories premium brand has hundreds
of affordable sunglass sunglass styles
to choose from constructed with durable
acetate lightweight materials that for
that perfect reliable fit you don't have
to choose between style and function you
get both I love movement watches and
their sunglasses are just terrific as
well but they're free shipping and
return policy you can try on as many
styles as you want right from home my
wife has moved in sunglasses I have move
in sunglasses while they are awesome and
they're not gonna cost you an arm and a
leg movement sunglasses start at 60
bucks no pair prices over 95 bucks so
you are guaranteed to find a style you
love with quality that doesn't break the
bank get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro cy movement
keeps growing check out their expanding
collection go to MVM t.com slash capiro
join the movement that's MVM t.com slash
shapiro go check them out right now
great company and their practice awesome
I love it I mean I'm wearing a movement
watch right now you can see it right
here upon my wrist I'd be wearing
sunglasses - but that's inappropriate
for my studio show go to movement comm
MV mt comm slash shapiro and join the
movement okay Robert Muller continues
with his big long awaited statement
again this is the first time he's spoken
publicly and he
and in the second volume the report
describes the results and analysis of
our obstruction of justice investigation
involving the president the order
appointing me special counsel authorized
us to investigate actions that could
obstruct the investigation and we
conducted that investigation and we kept
the office of the acting Attorney
General apprised of the progress of our
work and as set forth in the report
after that investigation if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so how's it there now that is a
line that people are jumping on
particularly members of the media if we
had evidence that the President did not
commit a crime we would have said so
that is not even close to a
prosecutorial standard that is not close
to a prosecutorial standard it's absurd
frankly that Muller would spill that in
public because the job of the Special
Counsel is not to exonerate the
President on charges the job of the
Special Counsel is in fact to determine
whether there is evidence sufficient to
prosecute can you imagine if every
prosecutor said listen I can't clear
this guy can't clear him that shifts the
burden of proof to the defendant right
the way that it works in our criminal
justice system is you actually have to
prove guilt you don't have to prove
innocence so what he is saying there is
that when Trump says he was exonerated
that's nonsense right this is obviously
Muller subtweeting Trump Trump has been
saying he was exonerated I have said all
along since the day of the Mallo report
no he was not exonerated but there was
not evidence sufficient charge according
to Muller himself Muller is obviously
subtweeting the president but he's
confusing the standard in the process
now there are a lot of people who are
saying what this really is is Muller
saying to Congress listen it's on you
guys right because the standard when it
comes to Congress is not proof beyond a
reasonable doubt
I didn't clear him that means that there
are some evidence of obstruction of
justice if you guys want to take that
and run all you guys but that is not his
purview right he's a special counsel his
job is not to recommend impeachment to
Congress that's the legislative branch's
job you now have a member of the
executive branch who apparently is
effectively saying to Congress do you
guys want to impeach the president Sall
on you guys all you it's very weird
stuff that Muller is doing here he's
acting defensive and really I mean
I don't think that it's up to his
standard of clarity for him to do that
I've been a longtime defender of Muller
I've said that I think the man is honest
I think that he has been doing his work
honestly but I don't think that it is
particularly honest for a special
counsel to get up there and say we
didn't clear the president that was not
your job that was not your job I
understand you're pissed off that Trump
is falsely claiming he was exonerated
when you said nothing about exoneration
or prosecution with that said that is
not the legal standard that ought to be
applied right here and it's kind of
dangerous they have special counsels
basically reversing the burden of proof
and saying that we didn't exonerate
Trump not your job to exonerate Trump
okay so in a second we're gonna continue
with Robert Muller statement when guy
Benson points out he's exactly correct
if Robert Muller had the evidence Muller
could have identified criminal conduct
and recommended charges and then let the
DOJ decide whether the OLC guidance
would or would not permit those charges
being filed against the sitting
president of the United States instead
he decided not to recommend anything
well gets his statements about the OLC
now so here is Robert Muller continuing
with his statements about obstruction we
did not however make a determination as
to whether the president did commit a
crime the introduction to the volume 2
of our report explains that decision it
explains that under long-standing
department policy a president president
cannot be charged with a federal crime
while he is in office that is
unconstitutional even if the charge is
kept under seal and hidden from public
view that too is prohibited is it there
so now what people are saying is that
the Attorney General William bar must
have lied because what Barr said is that
Muller told him that he was not going to
charge Trump even an absence of the OLC
statute or that he didn't have evidence
sufficient even under the OLC statute
here it seems to be saying what Robert
Mutt the way people are reading it if
they don't like President Trump and if
they want to prosecute Trump or impeach
him well the way that they're reading it
it's a plausible read is that Robert
Muller is basically saying we didn't
reach a determination and we didn't
reach your determination because the OLC
rules prevent us from making a
determination now that's not actually
true right that part's not actually true
you could make a determination as to
whether the president ought to be
prosecuted and then say but OLC rules
forbid it
that's not actually what Muller is
saying what Muller is actually saying to
be legally specific what Muller is
actually saying I think here is that the
OLC rules do not allow us to prosecute
the president because the oil C rules do
not allow us to prosecute the president
it was not important for us to actually
issue a ruling as to whether he is
prosecutable because he is not in fact
prosecutable so what that means is we
did not actually make the determination
so then the question becomes why were
you bothering to investigate this in the
first place if according to Muller the
oil C opinion prevents prosecution then
why did you bother investigating
obstruction of justice at any point here
because the president is not
prosecutable so why did we just spend
thirty million dollars investigating
obstruction of justice just to not just
to come to a conclusion that you could
have reached in the first five minutes
which is OLC rules forbid us from ruling
on this sort of stuff what is the point
of this now the what is the point of
this question is leading critics of the
president and and fans of impeachment to
say what Muller was really doing is on
the public dime he was setting up an
impeachment inquiry again what mowett is
saying here is OLC rules forbid me from
prosecuting the president therefore I
did not reach any sort of ruling on
whether the president is or is not
prosecutable so people are rightly
saying case of what was your job here
why were you investigating and if you're
forbidden from prosecuting for a
particular case of murder for example
let's say that there's a double
indemnity rule Oh Jay Simpson was
acquitted on his ex-wife's murder let's
say that the LAPD opens up a new
investigation on the basis of no new
evidence about OJ's murder of his
ex-wife well he's not prosecutable under
current criminal law in the United
States right there is a double jeopardy
provision that prevents you from
prosecuting someone twice for the same
crime let's say the LAPD does all of
that and then they come out with a
statement say by the way we kind of
think that OJ was guilty turns out okay
why are you wasting your time that's the
question here why is Robert Muller
wasting his time on investigating
obstruction of justice if he knew in the
first 30 seconds of his appointment that
he had no capacity to actually issue any
sort of opinion on prosecuting the
president and the answer that's being
given by some is that what he's actually
trying to do is set up the predicate for
an impeachment inquiry into the
president by Congress of the United
States I think that is probably right
I think that Muller in his heart of
hearts wants to see Trump impeached I
think he thinks that Trump is guilty not
guilty enough for him to prosecute and
not possible to prosecute him under the
OLC but certainly guilty enough for
impeachment which again has a different
criminal standard not the criminal
standard of the criminal justice system
it's a political standard I think that's
why people who are on the right many of
them are saying that's not Miller's job
why is Muller actually now engaged in in
setting up all of the dominoes for
impeachment for Democrats that's that's
kind of the math here so the math here
seems to be not that that Muller would
have recommended prosecution in the
absence of the OLC ruling because he
himself says I didn't reach a
determination on that but that he is
more saying okay well if Congress wants
to impeach I said it all out for you
here it's a 448 page report boom right
on the table Muller continues the
special counsels office as part of the
Department of Justice and by regulation
it was bound by that department policy
charging the president with a crime was
therefore not an option we could
consider the department's written
opinion explaining the policy makes
several important points that further
informed our handling of the obstruction
investigation those points are
summarized in our report and I will
describe two of them for you first the
opinion explicitly explicitly permits
the investigation of a sitting president
because it is important to preserve
evidence while memories are fresh and
documents available now he is saying we
had to do all of this so he's answering
the question we just asked okay so you
couldn't prosecute him so what the hell
was hope this about he says what we
wanted to keep the memories fresh I'm
sorry you're not the historical record
business my friend hey you're not a
librarian it is not your job to spend
taxpayer dollars to keep memories fresh
if you have no actual process for
prosecution and if prosecution is not
going to be available after the
president leaves office
Faithie well now that's the other
question maybe what Muller is doing here
is setting up the evidence not only for
impeachment for the possibility that if
the president is no longer president
then he could be prosecuted for
obstruction of justice right that after
Trump is no longer president no longer
sitting president
J could come after him for obstruction
of justice maybe that is what Muller is
saying here maybe that's the case that
he's making we have to preserve the
historical record for future prosecution
even though under OLC regulations we
can't prosecute him right now
that's a possibility the Muller is
leaving open let's play more of that in
just one second first let's talk about
your neighborhood and making it safer
rings mission is to make neighborhood
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring hopes you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert you'll be able to
see hear and speak to them all from your
phone that is thanks to HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices
so I have ring at my house I am deeply
concerned about personal security as you
all know I get a lot of death threats I
get a lot of people who are not huge
fans and that means that I really care
about safety on my property that's why I
rely on ring as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now why shouldn't you
have the same security I do the video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to start building a ring of
security around your home just go to
ring comm slash Ben that is ring comm
slash pen make your property safe or
make sure that your family is safe
the fact is that one of the ways that
burglars come into your house very often
is they ring the doorbell to see whether
you're home or not
with the ring kit they ring your
doorbell and you can pick up from your
phone so they don't know whether you're
home or not go check them out right now
at ring.com slash Ben for the special
deal that's ring comm / Ben okay so
we're going through Robert Muller
statement in detail so far he's made a
couple of key points the key point seems
to be number one that he says that OLC
regulations that the Department of
Justice Office of Legal Counsel
regulations prevented him from making a
determination as to the guilt or
innocence of President Trump on
obstruction of justice hey and a lot of
people are taking that to mean well if
the president weren't the president he'd
prosecute him maybe maybe not he didn't
reach that determination and then he
makes the broader point that the
president is not exonerated because he's
just not examined but again that's not
his standard the question is you
basically Muller has left it as vague as
it was before we don't know whether
Muller would prosecute him in the
absence of OLC standards the only thing
that we do know is that Barr said in
April before Congress quote rod Rosen
Stein and I asked Robert Muller when we
met with him on March 5th whether he
would have made obstruction a crime but
for the oil
the opinion he made it clear several
times that it was not his position so
unless bar is perjuring himself which
presumably
niemoller will be called to testify
about that by democrats they're not
gonna let him off this easy unless Barr
perjured himself this means that what
Muller really is doing here is setting
up an impeachment inquiry when Muller is
really doing here is saying to Democrats
in Congress listen I provided you the
roadmap criminal standards criminal
justice standards are not the same as
impeachment standards go with God it's
on you now and it's pretty obvious that
listen you read the report it's obvious
that Muller steam wanted to see Trump
burn me and I'm not saying that they
were unjustified in their assessment of
Trump's behavior Trump's behavior is
egregious in the Mullen report I mean
really really bad behavior whether that
rises to the level of criminality is
questionable and whether that level of
behavior rises to the level of
impeachment I sort of doubt it
I don't think it prevents Trump from
acting as an effective president in the
absence of openly criminal conduct in
any case robert muller continues with
his statement among other things that
evidence could be used if there were
co-conspirators who could be charged now
and second the opinion says that the
Constitution requires a process other
than the criminal justice system to
formally accuse a sitting president of
wrongdoing directly calling on
impeachment right there right what is
the process other than the criminal
justice system to accuse the president
of wrongdoing that is Miller openly
calling on impeachment right that is the
impeachment process that he's invoking
right there as I say I think that the
Muller report is basically a roadmap to
impeachment not a criminal justice
standard not a criminal which means that
he wasn't actually doing the job he was
supposed to be doing he was doing the
job that Congress was supposed to be
doing which does cast some questions on
what exactly was the purpose of the
Special Counsel report in the first
place and when it came to the Starr
report the Starr report uncovered overt
criminal activity and the Starr report
recommended impeachment based on actual
crimes actual crimes Muller report
doesn't recommend even criminal activity
doesn't even say the criminal activity
took place but they're saying okay well
if you investigate maybe you can come to
some sort of impeachable offense buried
somewhere in here mother continues and
beyond Department policy we were guided
by principles of
fairness it would be unfair to
potentially it would be unfair to
potentially accuse somebody of a crime
when there can be no court resolution of
the actual charge so that was Justice
Department policy
those were the principles under which we
operated and from them we concluded that
we would would not reach a determination
one way or the other about whether the
president committed a crime that is the
opposite that is the opposite final
position and we will not comment on any
other conclusions or hypotheticals about
the president posit there that so that
last statement is him saying that if
they call me to testify if Democrats
called me to testify and if they asked
me whether I would prosecute Trump in
the absence of the OLC memo I'm not
going to answer them right that is what
Muller is saying right there he's saying
basically here is the giant ink blot
that I've provided to you read in it
what you will this is no longer my job
I've given you everything that you asked
me to give you I even went beyond the
boundaries of what really I should be
doing right which is uncovering criminal
conduct so if you got a problem with
that too bad go read the report we
conducted an independent criminal
investigation and reported the results
to the Attorney General as required by
Department regulations the Attorney
General then concluded that it was
appropriate to provide our report to
Congress and to the American people at
one point in time I requested that
certain portions of the report be
released the Attorney General prepared
preferred to make that and preferred to
make the entire report public all at
once and we appreciate that the Attorney
General made the report largely public
and I certainly did not question the
Attorney General's good faith in that
decision that's it there
so this debunks one of the Democrats
talking points and the Democrats talking
point is that Barr obstructed the report
because he didn't want the public to
know about what was in there and that he
was stopping Robert Muller's great
information from reaching the public
this was always a stupid contention bar
put out his final legal finding his
original four-page legal finding was a
legal finding it had nothing do with
impeachment remember what Muller is
mostly talking about here his
impeachment stuff he's mostly not talk
about criminal justice stuff bar is
talking specifically about criminal
justice stuff is the president worthy of
prosecution bar says no that was his
four-page letter and then three weeks
later he releases the entire report and
this is Muller himself saying that was
not a delay that was designed to
obfuscate that was not a delay that was
designed to allow bard to hide anything
Muller himself is saying Barr was honest
when it came to releasing the report
that gets rid of one major democratic
talking point which is that somehow in
those three weeks the entire narrative
was spun and the report was somehow
corrupted Moses listen you can go buy it
on Amazon you want to read the report go
buy the report you can read it on it you
can read it for free online
enjoy yourself the fact is that I don't
think this what Muller is saying I don't
think that attorney general Barr was
doing something deeply wrong in waiting
to release the entire report as a piece
and I don't doubt his motivation in
doing that so there goes one Democratic
talking point Muller continues now I
hope and expect this to be the only time
that I will speak to you in this manner
I am making that decision myself no one
has told me whether I can or should
testify or speak further about this
matter there has been discussion about
an appearance before Congress any
testimony from this office would not go
beyond our report posit there he's
saying I don't want to testify and that
is not Trump stopping me that does not
bar stopping me that is me stopping me I
don't feel like testimony now Democrats
are gonna subpoena him they're gonna ask
him specifically the only question that
matters in the absence of the OLC report
would you prosecute the president right
that's that's the only question they're
gonna be able to ask him and did
Attorney General bar lie when he said
that you wouldn't or that at least that
was not your determining factor your
sole determining factor that's gonna be
the question that they asked Muller
there's no question Democrats call him
at this point
but Muller saying listen I'm a lawyer I
wrote this thing read it enjoy it's not
obstructed Democrats been claiming that
Muller is being obstructed by the Trump
administration from testifying there is
Robert Millar killing another Democratic
talking points a lot a lot of talking
points are dying today in this Muller
report talking point number one from the
Trump side Trump's been exonerated he
has not talking point number two from
the Trump side is that President Trump
is not worthy of impeachment because no
criminal justice action was taken
one is still open because again the
difference between impeachment and
Criminal Justice is that impeachment is
a political standard criminal justice is
a legal standard those are two talking
points from the Trump side talking
points from the left that there is
obstruction by attorney general bar
that's been basically to bunk here and
also the idea that there's current
obstruction taking place that Muller
would testify were it not for the evil
Trump administration another saying no I
don't want to talk to you guys you're
annoying me it's basically the Muellers
statement here now we're gonna get to
the rest of Muller statement in just one
second first hiring used to be hard
multiple job sites stacks of resume a
confusing review process but today
hiring can be easy you only have to go
to one place to get done
zip recruiter com slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one they spotlight the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective at four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day it is so effective we use it here at
daily wire which is one of the reasons
why if there's a screw-up on the show a
zip recruiter chosen person could
replace someone here today I know this
is basically like that scene from The
Dark Knight where the Joker splits the
view of the pool cue and then to set but
hey men we run a business around here
and you can do it zip recruiter right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruit comm slash daily wire that
is zip recruiters comm slash daily wire
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly Wira zip
recruiters indeed the smartest way to
hire okay we'll get to the rest of the
Muller statement today the
groundbreaking earth-shaking Muller
statement we'll also get to justin amash
the michigan congress person who's now
pushing for impeachment there's no
question impeachment talk is gonna heat
up after Muller statement we'll get to
all that in just a second first go
subscribe over at daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live like you get the rest of the show
plus you get two additional hours this
afternoon we're gonna have plenty of
guests to talk about what Muller said
hear what legal standards should be
we're gonna get into abortion we're
gonna get into all sorts of hot-button
issues because we do every day here on
the bench Shapiro show that just cost
you $9.99 a month now I make an explicit
appeal to you one of the reasons that we
need you to subscribe is because it does
make us corn
technology proof it prevents the left
from targeting us and trying to make our
show unsustainable I mean this is there
are people who listen to the show every
day at Media Matters who are
deliberately attempting to take down the
show on a daily basis one of the things
that helps us prevent that sort of
garbage is your subscription so we
really appreciate you helping us out
also when you spend ninety nine bucks a
year you get the annual subscription
which comes along with this the leftist
year's hot or cold tumbler check that
out oh yeah that's good stuff right
there you get that for ninety nine
dollars a year which is cheaper than the
monthly subscription also we have great
Sunday specials coming up like terrific
ones coming up every summer you get
those on Saturday when your subscriber
plus questions that are behind the
paywall you to ask questions in our
mailbag all sorts of goodies go check us
out right now also check us out at
YouTube and iTunes once again we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so we're finishing up with
the Muller statement here so Muller is
quickly reaching his conclusion about
his report he continues it contains our
findings and analysis and the reasons
for the decisions we made we chose those
words carefully and the work speaks for
itself
and the report is my testimony I would
not provide information beyond that
which is already public in any
appearance before Congress in addition
access to our under the underlying work
product is being decided and a process
it doesn't that does not involve our
office so beyond what I've said here
today and what is contained in our
written work I do not believe it is
appropriate for me to speak further
about the investigation or to comment on
the actions of the Justice Department or
Congress and it's for that reason I will
not be taking questions today as well
now before I step away I want to thank
the attorneys the FBI agents the
analysts the professional staff who
helped us conduct this investigation in
a fair and independent manner these
individuals who spent nearly two years
with the special counsels office were of
the highest integrity and I will close
by reiterating the central allegation of
our indictments that there were multiple
systemic efforts to interfere in our
election and that allegation deserves
the attention of every American thank
you thank you for being here today
okay so at the very end that is him
again slapping at president Trump who
has been ripping on Muller steam is the
99 gree Democrats and all of this so
here's what this sets up and now things
get interesting
what Muller as I have been saying
basically says here is there may be
enough in my report for you to launch an
impeachment inquiry there is not enough
in my report for me to clearly state one
way or the other whether the president
engaged in criminal activity and good
news for me I can't do it anyway because
the OLC rules prevent me from doing that
and that is basically Muller statement
so now the ball is in
mccr at scorn and this is almost
Democrats worst nightmare in a way this
is almost the worst thing for Democrats
because most Americans have already come
to a conclusion about the report and
their conclusion is pretty simple and I
think correct the president acted
incredibly badly he acted dangerously
with regard to his handling of the truth
in fact but he handled this non
criminally and that means that they're
kind of tired of this and if you look at
the polls this is what Americans say
they say they are tired of the Russia
stuff they say they're not interested in
more of this they also say Trump was not
exonerated and they don't like Trump's
behavior all of those things can be true
at once in the American public I think
basically get it the problem for
Democrats is how are they going to
justify to their base not opening an
impeachment inquiry on the basis of what
Robert Muller just said Muller basically
just said the doors open to impeachment
enjoy here's a road map boom just pass
it right over I'm not gonna prosecute
because that's not what prosecutors do
but I didn't exonerate him so if you
guys want to go ahead and do it all you
Nancy Pelosi does not want to impeach
the president she is not interested in
Pietschmann inquiries she thinks that
Trump is beatable only if President
Trump is made the issue of the election
and that issue can't be corruption that
issue has to be character Nancy Pelosi
thinks that if Donald Trump acts like a
crazy person basically he loses the
presidency but if this turns into an
impeachment fight there will be a
backlash and most Americans will say
okay so basically this is badly
motivated there's a bunch of Democrats
who just want Trump out and now they're
looking for an excuse to do it
there's nothing prosecutable here Muller
didn't even recommend criminal
prosecution so we're done and most
Americans are ready to be done with this
but most members of the Democratic base
are certainly not ready to be done with
this so what Muller actually just did is
he gave impeachment a shot in the arm at
a time when Democrats don't necessarily
want it and you can see this gap between
the Democratic base and the Democratic
leadership emerging pretty much every
day now very few Republicans are calling
for impeachment at this point maybe the
only Republican that I can see who's
calling for impeachment is Justin Amash
who is the Republican Congress person
from Michigan now Amash is being ripped
up and down by a bunch of people on the
right who are saying that he's acting in
bad faith yeah I've had Justin Amash on
our radio program I think that he's a
solid libertarian I don't think he's
doing this in bad faith I don't think he
ulterior motives I think he believes
what he believes yesterday he did a long
town-hall event in which he talked about
president Trump's impeachment here's a
little bit of what it sounded like I
think it's really important that we do
our job as a congress that we not allow
misconduct to go undeterred I want to
salute your courage
now here's here's one of the things
that's happening here people are saying
well look Amash has a huge base of
people supporting him well no he said
that he wants the president impeach
there are a lot of people on the Left
who want the President impeached and so
he's gaining some strange new respect
right here you can see not a lot of
Trump voters in the room and Amash is
speaking about impeachment and he
receives that standing ovations and then
Amash is specifically asked about
whether he's just anti Trump and does
that make him non conservative NEBOSH
makes a pretty good point which is look
Trump is not the standard for
conservatism I have the best voting
record in Congress when it comes to
spending for example that's accurate the
conflation of Trump and conservatism is
not accurate with that said with that
said Amash is case for impeachment is
not particularly strong so Amash tweeted
out this long tweet thread yesterday
about William Bar and about President
Trump and I want to go through it
because I think that it is worthwhile
talking about the argument for
impeachment so we can be intellectually
honest about how strong it is or how not
strong it is so Justin Amash it's
amazing but a libertarian Republican
Congress person is making what I
consider to be the most legally tenable
case for impeachment that I've heard no
one on the Democratic side is making
this case Democrats are basically just
saying we hate Trump get him out I have
not heard an articulate case from anyone
on the Democratic side because here's
the problem they overshot the mark by a
wide margin by people like Adam Schiff
we're out there saying for years that
Trump was a Putin plant and when it
turns out he's not a Putin plant Adams
shift Adams chef is out there basically
with squat well Justin Amash here's
here's the case Justin Amash max so you
tweeted this out yesterday and I think
it's worth going through so that you
hear the argument and you hear the
counter-argument cuz I disagree with
with representative Hamas so he tweeted
out Attorney General bar has
deliberately misrepresented key aspects
of Muller's report and decisions in the
investigation which has helped further
the president's false narrative about
the investigation
after receiving Muller's report by wrote
and released a letter on March 24th
describing bars own decision not to
indict the president for obstruction of
justice that letter selectively quotes
and summarizes points in Muller's report
in misleading ways so now he's accusing
Barr of effectively acting as a wingman
for Trump says Muller's report says he
chose not to decide whether Trump broke
the law because there's an official DOJ
opinion that indicted a sitting
president is unconstitutional and
because of concerns about impacting the
president
ability to govern and pre-empting
possible impeachment buyers letter
doesn't mention those issues when
explaining why Muller chose not to make
a prosecutorial decision instead
selectively quotes Muller in a way that
makes it sound falsely as if Motors
decision stemmed from legal factual
issues specific to Trump's actions well
not really because what Barr says is
look I don't have the grounds for a
criminal prosecution because the fact is
that you have to find corrupt intent in
order to charge obstruction of justice
and the report as I have read it does
not actually reach the threshold
standard for corrupt intent necessary
under law Muller refused to come to a
conclusion and as Barr openly testified
Muller said to me that he was not clear
on whether he would prosecute the
president or not in the absence of OLC
considerations Amash says Muller finds
considerable evidence that several of
trumps actions detailed in the report
meet the elements of obstruction and
motives constitutional and Prudential
issues with inciting a sitting president
would preclude indictment regardless of
what he found okay well it is true that
Muller does suggest that there may be
evidence for prosecution but he does not
actually recommend prosecution which
theoretically he could have done he
could have said to Barr listen the OLC
report says I can't prosecute also if it
weren't for the oil see report I'd
prosecute it is also worthwhile noting
here that when Amash says basically that
that is what Muller is saying in that
report Muller himself does not say that
i'm ashlyn says in note and y-bar
thought the president's intents in
impeding the investigation was
insufficient to establish obstruction
Barr selectively quotes Muller to make
it sound as if his analysis was much
closer to bars analysis than it actually
was our quotes Muller saying the
evidence didn't establish that Trump was
personally involved in crimes related to
Russian and election interference and
bar then claims the Muller found that
fact relevant as to whether the
President had the intent to obstruct
justice actually that's not right
Barr does not say that Muller exonerated
Trump Barr said that Barr exonerates
Trump read Barr said that Muller did not
uncover underlying crime that would hint
at corrupt intent that would be
necessary to prosecute obstruction of
justice so I think Amash is just miss
reading bars letter here amash continues
Mona's quote is taken from a section in
which he describes other improper
motives Trump could have had and notes
the injury to the integrity of the
justice system is the same regardless of
whether a person committed an underlying
crime none of that is in bars letter L
doesn't
have to be in bars letter because again
in bars four-page letter is a synopsis
of the legal finding it is not a
synopsis of all of the bad crap that
Muller said about Trump if you want to
read all the bad crap Muller said about
Trump there's a 448 page report and it's
out there man and you know who
Declassified that and released it that'd
have been the Attorney General William
bar Amash then says as a result of bars
March 24th letter the public and
Congress were misled Muller himself
notes this in a March 27th letter to bar
saying the bars letter did not fully
capture the context nature and substance
of this offices work and conclusions and
then he quotes Muller talking about
there's public confusion about critical
aspects of the results of our
investigation and again as I said at the
time I think Muller was ticked off that
bars report basically was here's my
legal finding not here's all the bad
crap I have to say about President Trump
good news for both Muller and Justin
Amash we have the 448 page report
sitting before us so if bar was trying
to obstruct the bad crap about Trump
giant fail on his part Amash says to
alleviate the misunderstandings that
have arisen Muller urged the release of
the reports introductions and executive
summaries which he had told Barr
accurately summarized the offices work
in conclusions by our declined he
allowed the confusion to fester and only
released the materials three weeks later
with the full redacted report in the
interim Barr testified before a House
committee and was misleading about his
knowledge of Muller's concerns I was
asked about the reports that members of
Muller's team are frustrated with the
limited information included in her
March 24th letter that it does not
adequately or accurately necessarily
portray the report's findings do you
know what they're referencing with that
and Bart said no I don't I suspect that
they probably wanted more put out
okay well that's accurate yet Muller had
directly raised those concerns to bar
and bar says he suspects they probably
wanted more materials put out as if
Muller hadn't directly told them that
that's pretty weak t representative
Amash so in other words Bart said I
don't really know what they want
probably they just want more out there
but from a legal standard I don't really
get it and I'm not just saying that that
was Barra lying I don't think that's
correct
Amash continues in subsequent statements
and testimony Barr used further
misrepresentations to help build the
president's false narrative that the
investigation was unjustified Meyer
notes that Muller did not find any
conspiracy to violate US law involving
Russia linked persons and any persons
associated with the Trump campaign he
then declares that mullet found no
collusion and implies falsely the
investigation was baseless well no he
didn't say the investigation was
baseless he said that it may have
baseless but we do not know that at this
point Amash says whether there's enough
evidence for a conviction of a specific
crime which Muller thought was
appropriate to charge is a different a
much higher standard than whether the
people who Muller investigated had done
anything worthy of Investigation I agree
with that and what Amash is saying is
maybe the investigation was initiated
under proper auspices and it didn't find
any crime I'm perfectly willing to hear
that but I don't think the bar is
basically disagreeing with that Amash
then continues he says the report says
that the president's counsel was told
that interviewing him was vital to
Muller's investigation and that would be
in the interest of the public and the
presidency still Trump refused the
president instead gave written answers
submitted by the special counsel Mullen
found them in adequate again sought to
interview the president ultimately the
special counsel recognized that the
president would not be interviewed
voluntarily and chose not to subpoena
him because of concerns that the
resulting litigation would delay the
completion of the investigation okay I
think everybody recognizes the real
reason Trump wasn't getting in front of
the special counsel is because Trump
talks a lot a lot of stuff falls out of
that face right there and the
possibility that a lawyer would ever let
Trump talk in front of a of an FBI
investigator he'd ask me insane as
Trump's lawyer to let him do that
the chances that he perjures himself
just by being trump i restored entirely
hi this is a guy who says he knows
everything there is to know about
airplanes I mean that's who president
rhombic oh if you're his lawyer there's
no way you let him get in front so Amash
is making the case for impeachment I
think that it's a weak case but there's
gonna be a lot of pressure on Democrats
now to move forward with impeachment in
the aftermath of all of this I think
that's a big mistake for Democrats I
think Nancy Pelosi knows it so in some
ways you know it's a bad news day for
president Trump in some ways it's a bad
news day for Nancy Pelosi because
suddenly the onus is on her okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so things that I like
today and if you saw this thing from
America's Got Talent not assure that I
watch but it started making the rounds
yesterday it's an amazing amazing clip
so there's this guy Kent remember his
name who went who is autistic and blind
and he is brought on to America's Got
Talent to play a song and sing and he's
led out there by his mom and he sits
down at the piano and then this happens
[Music]
she's in my life and time
assaults in a made some bad words
[Music]
amazing so that is Donny Hathaway's a
song for you that he is singing his mom
said and told the crowd we found out
that he loved music really early on
through music and performing he was able
to withstand living in this world
because when you're autistic it's really
hard to do what everyone else does and
has actually saved his life playing
music everybody was basically crying
Italy was advanced straight to the
finals of America's Got Talent as well
he should be that's an amazing amazing
thing God creates all sorts of miracles
this guy is a miracle and that is an
amazing thing and I just like to remind
folks that there are a lot of people who
believe that people who are autistic and
but people have a condition like that if
you find out that your kid is gonna be
like that in the womb that abortion is
an appropriate solution I know that that
is not a video about abortion but to me
it's a video about the innate value of
human life and the creativity of human
beings I mean every life is indeed
invaluable and this guy is that a proof
positive of that just amazing stuff
really really amazing okay other things
that I like so there's a movie that I
watched over the weekend that has gotten
no attention I have to admit I am a
Gerard Butler fan but the big question
about Gerard Butler was can he act it
turns out the answer is yes there's this
really creepy little almost horror film
called The Vanishing that's almost a
riff on Treasure of the Sierra Madre
about what happens to three people when
they discover a chest of gold their
lighthouse keepers and Gerard Butler is
pretty terrific in it the movie didn't
get huge play but the movie is pretty
good here's a little bit of a trailer we
don't talk about this
you tell no one and I mean absolutely no
one
one more spoken and we are dead and when
we get back
nothing we carry on and you do exactly
as I say
[Music]
movies worth watching is pretty cool so
go check out that movie it's it's pretty
pretty good stuff okay time for a couple
of things that I hate okay so thing that
I hate number one
the it's pretty incredible there is a
there is a study that is out today and
what the study shows of course of course
is that effectively speaking all of the
talk about white privilege that is
supposed to make America stronger does
not in fact do that the study according
to Robbie suave writing at recent
Robbie's a really good columnist over
there he says does educating people
about white privilege the idea that for
white people their race is a boon but
for black people a drawback at least in
certain social situations make them more
empathetic a fascinating new study
suggests that the kind of racism
awareness training taught in many
university classrooms is not only
useless but it's actually detrimental
the study was published in the Journal
of Experimental Psychology in April
researchers provided participants with
some academic literature explaining the
concept of white privilege and then
asked them to gauge their reactions to
hearing a story about an unfortunate man
for some participants the man was
described as black for others he was
described as white researchers also ran
a separate experiment in which the
participants were not told about white
privilege before reacting to the story
and then they queried both sets of
participants about their political
beliefs what they found is that
conservatives who had learned about
white privilege were no more sympathetic
to the poor black man than conservatives
who had not learned about white
privilege for liberals the results were
alarming liberals who read the
educational materials about white
privilege were similarly unsympathetic
to the poor black man as liberals in the
second experiment but they were even
more unsympathetic to the poor white man
so in other words all the talk about
white privilege makes liberals worse
people conservatives are exactly the
same like okay well you know what I'm
gonna call bullcrap on all that and
people who are poor are poor and people
who are not poor are not poor and we
don't care and liberals went ok well we
now agree that white privilege is is a
thing that's not gonna make me any more
sympathetic to black people cuz we're
already super sympathetic to black folks
but if there's a poor white guy screw
that guy white privilege which is
predictably the outcome everyone who has
watched politics or dealt with people in
politics knows this
anybody who's dealt with folks on a
college campus knows this this is the
way
of the interpretation of kimberlé
crenshaw intersectionality that
predominates on college campuses now
there are people who say that's a
misinterpretation of Crenshaw's theory
fine whatever if you're going to talk
about how it is actually applied in real
life on college campuses it is exactly
this garbage where you are told that
poor white people are privileged poor
black people are not privileged and
therefore we have to be unsympathetic to
poor white people this experiment is
proof positive as to what everyone knows
Aaron Cooley is one of the study's
authors and an assistant professor of
psychology at Colgate she is what we
found startling was that white privilege
lessons didn't increase liberal sympathy
for poor black people instead the
lessons decreased liberals sympathy for
poor white people which led them to
blame white people more for their own
poverty they seemed to think that if a
person is poor despite all the
privileges of being white there really
must be something wrong with them yep
there you go so that is that that is
solid stuff thank you college campuses
for making it the world worse it can
always be counted on to really do that
sort of yeoman's work okay well we're
gonna be back here later today with a
lot more gonna talk about
Clarence Thomas writing a blistering
concurrence in an abortion case at the
Supreme Court we're also gonna do some
more analysis of the Muller statement
what it means for the future of
impeachment we'll get to all of that
today a little bit later on two
additional hours today this is why
should subscribe if not we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody's Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show Robert Muller has
made a statement and James Comey has
written an op-ed for the Washington Post
and both former FBI guys have made it
clear they don't like Donald Trump and
they think their investigations were
peachy keen and I think we should listen
very carefully to what they have to say
before we make a final decision as to
how many of these guys we can send to
prison where they belong that's on the
Andrew Clavin show plus the mailbag
I'm Andrew Clavin